I've never owned a precon Wizards of the
Coast has been releasing preconstructed
Commander decks ever since I started
playing in 2011 and with increasing
frequency and I've just kept on ignoring
them the reason for this is simple
enough I didn't start playing Commander
until 2014 at which point I felt like a
skilled enough player to build my own
mono removal pile to piss off my friends
however as I've continued to make videos
and exist more in the mggg space it's
become increasingly clear to me that
precons play a major role in the way
people learn and conceptualize the EDH
for format so I figure I should take a
moment to engage with the world of
precons I pulled my patrons and they
thought I should look at the blame game
precon so I'm going to do just that I'm
going to break down what I think the
deck is trying to do how well it's
accomplishing that plan and some
potential Improvement routes for making
it function better let's first break
down what the commander is offering
Nelly's first ability contains the
suspect component which offers immediate
evasion by disabling a blocker as well
as the go component which offers a way
to keep threats away from our life total
as long as Nelly keeps attacking and
guarantees that our opponents will be
attacking each other the second ability
is a source of draw that can offer up to
three cards per turn cycle while also
feeding opponents that Resource as a
reward for hitting each other whether
due to being compelled or otherwise this
is a pretty fun package the first
ability will scale to great effect over
time and the second ability offers some
fun politics gameplay and discourages
our opponents from removing Nelly for
fear of losing out on those sweet sweet
cards less to the point of this video
the flavor here is great a commander
that is constantly accusing people of
murder which is causing the accused to
lash out in order to Curry favor as long
as Nelly is around good stuff to go
along with the commander the deck is
running lots of cards with the intent of
getting our opponents to attack each
other rather than attacking us there are
a bunch of good cards there are cards
that give people advantages for
attacking our opponents there are cards
that punish people for attacking us and
so on basically the deck is trying to
control the mid game by getting our
opponents to fight amongst themselves
and Nelly draws cess additional cards
when they do this this card draw should
hopefully fuel a powerful Lake game
where a suite of bigger creatures means
that once our opponents are dropping in
life total and dwindling in number we
can take control of the game with our
board state so that's the game plan but
how effectively can the deck accomplish
it well there are a handful of things
that the deck is doing decently well
when it comes to fundamentals it has
eight cards that I can broadly label as
draw which isn't a bad number when
paired with a commander that will likely
be drawing one to two cards per turn
cycle there are also 11 cards that one
could label as ramp which is a solid
number and this also works well with a
creature base that includes a number of
higher costed beaters finishing off the
final opponent is something I'd
naturally worry about for a goat deck
but I think the creature base is just
beefy enough that the deck should be
able to finish off a game a lot of the
time as long as the commander has been
getting in the desired number of draw
triggers the deck contains nine cards
that I'd call removal and although I'm a
little concerned at how high cost most
of it is I'm mostly willing to overlook
that due to how many other options the
deck has for interacting with opposing
creatures the deck also includes 10
extra go cards which bolster the
Commander's card draw and will also help
keep the heat off us even if our
commander based go engine goes offline
what I don't like is the amount of other
player protective cards in the deck I
tallied up all the cards that discourage
or disallow attacking us in some way and
the total for these was 33 cards oneir
of the deck is is trying to get our
opponents to attack each other instead
of us and I get that that's a big thing
the deck is trying to do but 33 slots is
way too many for a task that won't win
or prevent our opponents from winning on
its own like okay the ideal scenario is
that you'll have key opposing creatures
being tossed around wildly with opposing
game plans and life totals crumbling
before our very eyes but how often will
this actually happen there will be games
where our opponents are developing
horrifying wincons that don't use combat
and we just sit there twiddling our
thumbs as we go their utility 23es into
Johnny noard over there and draw them
into the gas they need to murder us my
guess is that different defensive cards
are meant to serve somewhat different
purposes throughout the game but this is
quite inefficient slots wise
additionally and this is kind of a
pre-con classic but the Mana base is bad
37 lands might be an okay count in the
abstract But it includes 11 solely
colorless producing utility lands this
results in the deck having 20 white
sources and 17 red sources between its
artifacts and lands that's right this 37
land and six Rock two-color manabase has
symbol numbers that are similar to those
of the budget 30 land 4color manabase
from my lands video and this deck has
like 10 double red cards in it you need
26 red sources to consistently cast a
vengeful ancestor on curve and yet here
we are with 17 Wizards please just put
things to tap for colored Mana in your
pre Recons just do it I know you can
thank
you I ran 15 play tests with the deck
and my previous hunches were pretty well
backed up the deck can have a decent
mid-game curve out with solid ramping
and drawing capabilities but it
frequently has Mana issues and also
frequently get stuck on a handful of
nothing but Niche defensive cards
another issue that was on my radar but
which became much more clear in play
testing was that the deck has only a
handful of good three drops and
basically no two drops other than
rocks when I play tested it I was
aggressively mulliganing for early plays
which led to the deck having what I'd
consider to be a decent curve out eight
of the 15 play tests but I imagine a new
player piloting the deck would probably
happily keep a more average hand for the
deck one that plays nothing on turn one
and two a weird enchantment on turn
three and Commander on turn four which I
guess might work out in a game with
other precons but leaving your two drop
slot on the table in a two-color deck is
not good and will hurt your chances of
winning so yeah there are definitely
issues here but overall this deck has a
very fun useful commander and a pretty
solid mid-game plan of influencing the
attacks of the game and leveraging
politics to its favor it's pretty
well-rounded in most areas with the
three standout issues being mana base
Mana curve and an excess of defensive
cards so how do we go about tuning it up
for improving this deck I want to
maintain the affordability and spirit of
the deck but smooth out some of the
rough edges first of all I would want to
cut a bunch of defensive cards because
they are taking up too much goddamn
space in this deck specifically I
dislike the ones whose use cases are too
narrow whose effect is too limited or
which costs too much mana and there are
about a quarter of these that I would
cut right off the bat from there I think
it's up to the player to some extent I
opted to cut an additional six for my
final deck list in their place there are
a number of things that could be added
and I think a good option to somewhat
fill the same role is cards that Grant
haste if Nelly dies on the declare
combat step well that sucks for us but
if she dies any other time we want to be
able to play her again and keep her wall
of goat up I'd also add a bit of board
protection in if Nelly gets destroyed
we're vulnerable to attacks and if the
board gets wiped we lose basically all
momentum next up let's talk manabase the
goal here is simple we want several more
symbols of each color and to get there
we cut colorless lands and rocks for
once that produce colored Mana I like a
lot of the utility lands in principle
evasion is good graveyard hate is good
draw is good so I'm going to start with
the ones I see as adding basically
nothing to the deck Temple of the false
god is weird and very bad if you're
running less than like 43 other lands
Relic Tower and thought vessel are next
up on my list this deck doesn't
draw insane numbers of cards and it also
doesn't need to hold up a bunch of
interaction and Niche Tech pieces I'd
also cut care and I'd consider cutting
some number of scavenger grounds thrown
of the high City and Sun home if the
deck was going to stay at the same land
count though these cards at least have
some identifiable purpose here speaking
of land count I think there are two
options for this deck with regard to
Mana curve option A would be to keep the
higher curve at a couple lands and add
four to five two cat rocks in order to
make sure that we're able to swing with
the commander on turn four as often as
possible I'd also fill out the deck with
a few more beaters in order to guarantee
that we'll have the raw power to finish
off the final player option b would be
to drop the curve and add a bunch of two
and three drop creatures that could lead
to us having a more aggressive game plan
I think either of these two game plans
would be valid but in my list I went for
option A as it seemed more in line with
the original plan of the deck though you
could certainly make a much better Deck
with this Commander my goal here was to
only swap out 20 cards to scrape out a
bit of the preon Jank factor and make
the deck play more smoothly I posted the
original deck as well as the improved
version I made in the description so you
can check out the changes I made and let
me know in the comments if you think I
utterly bastardized the entire point of
the deck this is also a bit different
than most of my other videos so you can
let me know if this sort of content is
something you want to see more of in the
future all right bye
now